شكرا لزميل احمد الهادي مستمرون معكم في
تغطتنا للتطورات المتسارعه في السودان بين
طرفي النزاع الجيش بقياده الجنرال عبد
الفتاح البرهان والدعم السريع بقياده
الجنرال محمد حمدان
اتهامات متبادله بين الطرفين بخرق الهدنه
الخامسه على وقع اشتباكات
متقطعه داخل العاصمه وخارجها طلعات جويه
للجيش تتواصل في سماء الخرطوم وسمعوا
اصوات المضادات الارضيه للدعم السريع في
الوقت الذي تتسابق فيه دول العالم لاجلاء
الرعايه اعلنت انقره تعرض طائره اجلاء
تركيا لاطلاق نار بمطار وادي سيدنا في
الخرطوم ولا اصابات الجيش السوداني اتهم
الدعم السريع باستهداف الطائرات التركيه
والاخير
ينفي
[موسيقى]
كما ترون انه مسجد بداد السوق المركزي
تدمر نهائي كل الدكاكين اللي في الس
وق
قوه الانفجار
سيد البرهان والسيد حميد تبعي نسبه لتعب
الشعبي وللمعاناه التي عاناها الشعب
السوداني
رحب اعضاء الاليه الثلاثيه التي تضم
الاتحاد الافريقي والهيئه الحكوميه
الدوليه والامم المتحده اضافه الى المملكه
العربيه السعوديه والامارات وبريطانيا
وامريكا رحبوا باعلان الجيش السوداني
وقوات الدعم السريع تمديد وقف اطلاق النار
الحالي لمده اثنتين وسبعين ساعه اضافيه
ودعوا الى تنفيذه بالكامل كما رحبت
الاطراف باستعداد طرفي النزاع في السودان
للدخول في حوار من اجل تحقيق لتحقيق وقف
دائما للاعمال العدائيه وضمان وصول
المساعدات الانسانيه دون عوائق
[موسيقى]
وكان الجيش السوداني اعلن هدنه جديده
استجابه لمساع سعوديه امريكيه واعرب الجيش
السوداني عن امله في التزام من وصفهم
بالمتمردين في اشاره لقوه الدعم السريع
لمتطلبات سريان الهدنه واوضح الجيش
السوداني ان تمديد الهدنه تم استجابه
لمساعا سعوديه امريكيه لتهيئه الظروف
لاجلاء المقيمين من مختلف الجنسيات بدورها
اصدرت قياده الدعم السريع السوداني بيانا
تضمن شكرا وتقديرا للاليه الثلاثيه
واللجنه الرباعيه وشكرت المملكه العربيه
السعوديه والولايات المتحده على جهودهما
المستمره في اجراء المواطنين والمقيمين
منذ اندلاع الازمه في السودان
واعلن بيان الدعم السريع الالتزامهم
بمقترح الثلاثيه والرباعيه بتمديد الهدنه
الانسانيه لمده 72 ساعه بدا من الثاني عشر
من مساء يوم الخميس السابع والعشرين من
ابريل الجري من جانبها رحبت القوى المدنيه
المواقعه على الاتفاق الايطالي في السودان
بالمبادره السعوديه الامريكيه لتمديد
الهدنه لمده 72 ساعه
وشددت على ضروره الالتزام بها من اجل
الوصول لوقف دائم ليطلق النار
واضافت انها تتابع عن كثب خطوات تنفيذ
المبادره الامريكيه السعوديه الراميه لوقف
المواجهات في السودان وتشد على ايدي قياده
القوات المسلحه والدعم السريع التي تعاطت
بايجابيه مع هذه المبادره
من ام درمان ينضم الينا الصحفي عمار ابو
شيبه عمار اهلا بك يعني بدايه دعني اسالك
عن الوضع الميداني هل هذه الهدنه ما زالت
قائمه رغم مشاهدتنا عبر شاشه العربيه وهذه
الصور الخاصه لنا للعربيه عبر هذه
الكاميرا
باعمده دخان في الخرطوم
دعم عادل
هذه الهدنه يبدو انها كسابقاتها لم تصمت
او لم يتم الحفاظ عليها الا في لحظات
معينه او في مناطق معينه وهذه ترتبط بشكل
واضح من خلال عمليه الاسلاك لعدم الرعايه
الاجانب في البلاد قبل دقائق من الان شن
الطيران الحربي للقوات المسلحه طلعت على
منطقه الريف الجنوبي
هذه المنطقه تتواجد فيها قوات الدعم
السريع كان هنالك
اشتباك في هذه المنطقه في ساعات الاولى من
صباح اليوم والان عاده طيران الحربي مره
اخرى واشن غارات على هذه المنطقه منطقه
بحري ايضا في هذا الصباح شهدت يعني
اشتباكات عنيفه على مستوى المنطقه الشرقيه
وفي اتجاه هذه المنطقه وهذا الاتجاه ايضا
تتحصل في الدعم السريع منذ اليوم الاول
وما زالت موجوده فيه وهنالك تصاعد السخان
في كثير جدا من هذه القناطر وحسب مصادر
اليها في تلك المنطقه هنالك حديث عن
اصابات لعده المنازل واصابات لعدد من
المحال التجاريه جراء القصف المتبادل ما
بين
الجانبين منطقه وسط الخرطوم في هذا الصباح
شهدت في يعني بحسب بيانات قوات الدعم
السريع تحدث بيان القوات من الدعم السريع
تحدثوا عن ان هنالك يعني انه تعرضوا
لخرق للهدنه وتعرض
لقصف في منطقه جبل اولياء هذه المنطقه تقع
الجنوب ولايه الخرطوم وهم يعني بحسب هذا
الخبر تحدثوا عن انه خرق الهدله والجيش رد
في بيان بانه القوات الموجوده في هذه
المنطقه هي من خلق البدله وهي من
اطلقت النار على عدد من
القوات الجيش الموجوده والم
حرش يبدو الوضع الميداني الان عامل بان
كثير من
المرئيه لوقف سيده الدماء وحمام الدماء
يبدو صعب جدا يعني تابعنا في الاخبار وقبل
قليل عن التعرض طائره التركيه التي اتت
للاجلال لعدد من الطلقات او الاصابات
بمنطقه وادي سيدنا في مدينه
خلف يعني هذه المعلومات كثيره جدا يعني
يبدو انها غائبه هذه المعلومات حتى الان
ولكن بحسب الجيش بانه ينتهي الدعم السريع
لهذه
عمار فقط خلي اشير الى هذا العاجل
اشتباكات قربه القصر الرئاسي في الخرطوم
وكذلك في منطقه بحري عمار يعني هل من
مؤشرات من اطلق النار هل يعني نعلم
الطرفين يتبادلان الاتهامات بخرق الهدنه
ولكن ماذا عن الطيران هل كان ربما استهداف
الطائره على يعني طيران منخفض ام بمضاد
طائرات
حسب المعلومات التي وردت اليها بان
الطائره يعني ضربت بمضادات للطيران
وبحكم تركيبه هذه الطائره وهي طائره كبيره
يعني الاجلاء وطائره عسكريه لها بحسب
تحصيناتها وبحسب المقدره العسكري لهذه
الطائره استطاعت الى محطه وادي سيدنا في
منطقه ام درمان الدعم السريع يقول في هذه
النقطه بان هذه المنطقه التي زواجت فيها
الطائره لا توجد قوات لدعم التاريخ لهذه
المنطقه والجيش يقصد سيطرته عليها ولكن
كان هناك حديث من القوات المسلحه بانه
هنالك من الجيوب وعدد من القوات من الدعم
السريع
تحاول ليله الامر ان تتوغل في محيط هذه
المنطقه وهذه
محيط المطار نحن نتحدث عن مر حتى افهم
الصوره بكل وضوح يعني قوات الدعم السريع
تحاول الدخول الى منطقه
مطار هذه المطار مطار سيدنا وادي سيدنا
هذه المنطقه عسكريه للقوات المسلحه تقع في
مدينه
الجيش كانت بان هنالك الجيوب داخل هذه
المنطقه
عدد من السيارات لم يتحدث
عن هذا الع
دد هذه القوه ولكن هذه القوه كان هناك
حديث بانها تفرقت في عدد المناطق واصبحت
يعني هنالك الديوله امنيه في هذه المنطقه
وهذا يذهب لان
الجيش ولكن القوات تقول بانها لا تتواجد
في هذه
المتابعه والشاهد في هذه المنطقه ايضا ان
الجيش يقصف سيطرته عليه يبقى هنا السؤال
الذي
اطلق هذه المضادات الارضيه هذا السؤال
كبير ربما نحتاج كثير جدا من المعلومات
حتى نستفيدين ونتاكد اكثر
حول هذه العمليه ولكن هذه العمليه ترتبط
بعمليات اخرى كثيره في وسط العاصمه
الخرطوم عند عمليات الاجلاء الاولى ايضا
هناك دراسات كثيره تعرضت
لاصابات تتعرض
يعني لم تثبت من الذي اطلق النار ولكن هذه
العمليه الاولى التي يتم اطلاق بها النار
على طائره طيب انا باختصار اذا سمحت لي
عمار ما هو بنك الاهداف للطيران الحربي
نتحدث عن اليوم منذ الصباح ساعات الصباح
وحتى الان
اذا اجملت لي بنك الاهداف التي استهدفها
الطيران الحربي
يعني بحسب البيانات العسكريه الوارده
صالحه في الريف الجنوبي لمدينه ام درمان
ومناطق في مدينه بحري منطقه كافوري
والمنطقه الصناعيه وعدد من المناطق
اللي فيها
بمنطقه جنوب الخرطوم منطقه جبل اولياء
شكرا جزيلا يا صحفيه عمار ابو شيبه من ام
درمان
حصلت قناه العربيه على صور حصريه لعمليات
الاجلاء الجويه للرعايه الاجانب من
السودان التي تجري تحت اشراف الجيش
السوداني حيث تظهر الصور اصطفاف طائرات
عسكريه لاجلاء الرعايه الاجانب وحتى
السودانيين
[موسيقى]
هذا واظهرت صورنا تم التقاطها بطائره دون
طيار استمرار عمليات الاجلاء للمواطنين
والدبلوماسيين في الميناء البحري الرئيسي
في شرق السودان
[موسيقى]
كما تابعت كاميرا العربيه اللحظات الاولى
لوصول السفينه الجلاله الملك الجبيل الى
قاعده الملك فيصل البحريه بمدينه جده في
السعوديه
نشاهد بدا عمليات تجهيز السلم لبدء انزال
الرعايه
القادمين من ميناء بورتسودان وعددهم 52
شخص من من 12 جنسيه نتحدث على دبلوماسيين
وعائلات واطفال وحتى كذلك كبار سن لانه
شاهد القوات العسكريه متواجده لاستقبال
الرعايه هنا في هذا في رصيف قاعده الملك
فيصل البحريه بعد رحله استمرت عشره ساعات
كنا على متن هذه السفينه نرافقها من قاعده
الملك فيصل البحريه بجده الى ميناء بورت
السودان واستمرت عمليات الاجلاء في ظرف
ساعه واحده فقط عبر زوارق سريعه قامت بنقل
الرعايه من ميناء بورتسودان الى
ظهر هذه السفينه السفينه جلاله الملك
الجبيل التابعه للقوات البحريه السعوديه
ومن ثم انطلقت مباشره من المياه الاقليميه
السودانيه الى قاعده الملك فيصل البحريه
بجده في رحله استغرقت كذلك عشره ساعات
فيما يتعلق بالتجهيزات الخاصه بالرعايه
هنا قامت القوات البحريه السعوديه غرف
نومتكانات لهؤلاء الرعايه وكذلك توفير
كافه المواد التموينيه والاعاشيه وكذلك تم
الكشف والتاكد من صحه وسلامه كافه الرعايه
من خلال وجود عياده طبيه هي مجهزه للتعامل
مع الحوادث والاصابات وكذلك اجراء
العمليات الخفيفه من خلال الاطباء عسكريين
سعوديين متواجدون في هذه العياده للتعامل
مع اي حاله كذلك تم فتح كافه المواقع
المخصصه للاعاشه لهؤلاء الرعايه حتى
يستطيعوا التزود من الطعام والمشروبات وما
شابه ذلك طوال مده الرحله كذلك التعامل
بشكل انساني كبير جدا وواضح خلال طوال هذه
الرحله من خلال التعامل مع الرعايه وعند
اقترابنا من قاعده الملك فيصل البحريه
ودخلنا المياه الاقليميه السعوديه التقينا
بعدد كبير من الرعايه نتحدث على يعني
شرحوا وعبروا لنا عن امتنانهم وتقديرهم
الحكومه السعوديه
وقاموا بالسفر برا الى ميناء بورسودان في
مده او في مسافه تصل الى 850 كيلو متر
يعني وثقوا هذه اللحظات عند اقترابهم
لقاده الملك فيصل البحريه بجده والثقوا
عبرها هواتفهم هذه اللقطات واختلفت
المشاعر بعد ان كان هنالك مشاعر خوف وعدم
استقرار اختلفت كليا بعد وصولهم الى بر
الامان هنا على ارض على ارض السعوديه
وتحديدا فعلى رصيف قاعده الملك فيصل
البحريه بجده
تابعنا ايضا لحظات الاولى لوصول سفينه
جلاله الملك مكه الى قاعده الملك فيصل
البحريه بمدينه جده في السعوديه وعلى
متنها 195 شخصا من 18 جنسيه مختلفه وصلت
الان
جلاله الملك مكه وهذا تاكيدا على عمليات
استمرار عمليات استمرار الاجلاء الخاصه
بالرعايه من ميناء بورت سودان الى قاعده
الملك فيصل البحريه عبر السفن البحريه
الخاصه بالقوات السعوديه البحريه نتحدث
على متن سفينه جلاله الملك مكنتي وصلت
الان
1998 الشخص من نتحدث من 18
جنسيه جميعهم من المواطنين الاجانب وصلوا
الى قاعده الملك فيصل البحريه بعد رحله
استمرت قرابه العشره ساعات من بورت سودان
وتحديدا من ميناء بورت السودان
الى قاعده الملك فيصل البحريه الان بدا
عمليات الانزام من خلال تركيب السلم الخاص
بالرصيف البحري الخاص بقاعه الملك فيصل
البحريه دقائق معدوده وسوف يقومون بعمليات
الانزال بدءا من النساء وكبار السن وذوي
الاحتياج خاصه وبعد ذلك بقيه الركاب
[موسيقى]
منا مدينه بورتسودان ينضم الينا مراسل
العربيه نزار المقداوي نزار اهلا بك يعني
بدايه ما هي مشاهدتك حيث انت في بورتسودان
منذ ساعات الصباح حتى الان
المشاهدات مستمره والتغطيه مستمره لقناه
العربيه لمقالات وتداعيات هذه الازمه
المستمره بعد ان بدات
واخذت منحني يتعلق بازمه لجوء ونزوح داخلي
وايضا اجلاء من السودان الى خارج السودان
نحن الان في احد المراكز المعنيه بالتنسيق
وحصر وجمع كل من يرغب في مغادره السودان
من مختلف الجنسيات
والاسيويه والاوروبيه والامريكيه التي
بدات في التوافق
مدينه بورسودان على ساحل البحر الاحمر
بشرق السودان نحن هنا منذ ساعات الصباح
الاولى نراقب هذا المشهد ونراقب حركه
التدفق المستمره لمئات من الاسر التي فضلت
البقاء في هذا المركز الرئيس لتسليم
الجوازات وانتظار الجوازات والتدقيق في
الوثائق الثبوتيه ومعرفه مصير الجوازات
ومتى سيغادرون
الميناء وعبر البواخر وعبر القطع البحريه
العسكريه التي تصل تباعا الى ميناء
بورسودان قبل قليل كانت هنالك اعداد مقدره
تم تفويجهم من هذا المركز الرئيسي مباشره
الى احدى القطع البحريه التي ستغادر بعد
قليل من بورسودان الذي تشاهدونه الان على
الصوره هذا المكان على الميناء مباشره
ستغادر هذه الباخره بعد قليل الى المملكه
العربيه السعوديه لكن يظل هؤلاء في انتظار
الدور حتى تنجلي كل المراحل وبعدها مباشره
يتم تحديد الميقات الزماني لمغادره مئات
الاسر والعائلات التي تنتظر دورها وتنتظر
التنسيق التحدي الاكبر هنا يجابه
الجاليه السوريه او رعايه دوله تحديدا
الاعداد كثيره وصلوا بنحو 3,500
من ابناء الجاليه السوريه هنا في السودان
قديما يعني انا اتحدث انه ربما هذه يعني
الباخره قد تحمل على متنها سوريين او عرب
خلال هذه الرحله الى المملكه العربيه
السعوديه بامكان ايضا نزار ان تستطلع على
هؤلاء اذا كان بالامكان من الممكن ان
تتحرك الكاميرا وتتجول بينهم اذا تكرمت
اضافه الى انه بودي ان اتعرف عن الطريق هل
هي سالكه الى بورت سودان ماذا يروي
النازحون
نعم الطريق الطريق سالك من مدينه بورسودان
او من العاصمه الخرطوم الى مدينه بورسودان
الطريق سالك الجيش السوداني يعمل على
تامين الطريق هنالك تنسيق لهذه الرحلات
بين السفارات الموجوده في العاصمه
السودانيه الخرطوم وبين مختلف البعثات
والوحدات الفنيه والدبلوماسيه الموجوده
هنا في مدينه بورسودان الباخره التي كانت
قبل قليل ستغادر ميناء بورسودان استحمل
ايضا عدد من الجاليات وعدد من رعايه الدول
الاجنبيه سواء كان من سوريا او من اليمن
او من العراق او من الاردن او عدد من
الدول الاجنبيه هؤلاء الذين تشاهدونهم
الان عبر الصوره ايضا ينتظرون ان يستكملوا
الرحلاتهم ويستكملوا اجراءاتهم وبعدها
مباشره يغادرون الى بلدانهم
نستطلع نعم نعم نستطلع الى نستطلع بعض
الاراء ونتعرف على
اين وصلتم الان في اجراءات المغادره والله
حاليا عم حاولوا يجلو اكبر عدد ممكن من
العالم الموجودين هون بس للاسف الشديد هنن
عم يطالعوا العالم اللي معاهم جنسيات
العالم اللي معاهم اقامات بالنسبه
للسوريين اللي ما معهم جنسيات او اقامات
رح يتموا موجودين هون لبين ما الله يفرجها
يتم توفيق الاوضاع
وهون العالم فتره تانيه راح تبلش يخلص كل
شيء معه بالنسبه للطعام والشراب والمال ما
في اي حوالات تصل لهنا
والشعب هون في حاله انه ما بيحسن اغلبه
ويرجع على سوريا
فنحن عم نستنى اي خبر يصلنا لحتى نعرف نحن
نرسل على بر او اي مكان نكون فيه موجودين
وشكرا جزيلا لكل الشعب الذي ساندنا وشكرا
لكل احد كان مع الشعب السوري او مع الشعب
السوداني يعني هناك ايضا عدد من الاصوات
يحاول ان توصل رسالتها عبر العربيه حتى
نستطلع اكثر ونكون اكثر قربا منهم كيف
تمضي الامور الان هنا في بورسودان والله
هنا الامور طبعا زي ما بتشوفوا يعني في
عيل هنا مع عند من اي جنسيه كلها سوريه
انت سوري انا سوري نعم يعني في عيال هنا
في كبير السن في اطفال في نسوان اليوم بس
حابين انه يصل الكلام هذا في نسوان ما
عندها اي ملجا يعني ما تؤاخذني في الكلمه
هذه عايزين يمشوا الحمام مثلا ما في ما في
يعني هذه تعتبر اكبر مشكله بالنسبه لنا
نحن هنا كسوريين بالنسبه للاعداد الكبيره
بالنسبه للاعداد الكبيره يعني اليوم نحن
هنا الان اللي تسجل اللي تسجل الان بفوق
للاربعه الف ولسه في ناس قاعد تجي طيب
الناس اللي قاعد تجي هاي ايش مصيره راح
يكون هون الناس اللي جت هون الان كلياتها
اللي شايفتها عينك هنا ما ما ما عندها اي
غير رحمه الله يعني اليوم السعوديه
وقعدتنا انه يطلعوا الناس يطلعوا الناس
لجده ومن جده كان هم خايفين انه الناس هاي
اغلبيتها ما عندها
عن طريق العربيه انه يا اخي الحكومه
السعوديه اذا خايفه مننا انه نحن نخش
السعوديه وما نطلع منها ده احنا عندنا
المقترح هذا انه من الباخره لنا باصات
الباصات تجي مثلا المغرب بتاخذ الف
راكبروا لنا باصات بتاخد الف راكب بتركب
الناس من الباخره دغري بتطلع على على
سوريا ما عايزين نحنا ما احنا يعني اغلبيه
الناس هنا تطلعوا بامان بس همنا انه نطلع
ايوه يعني المعاناه الان شايف اي حد هنا
المعاناه اللي عمي يعانيها ما يعلم فيها
الا رب العالمين الاولويه الان حسب
السفاره والمعنينه الاولويه عشان يطلعوا
الاولويه للعائلات للعائلات في في اطفال
في كبار في السن في المصاوب في المرضان في
اللي عنده سكر في عنده ضغط في اللي عنده
عنده مشاكل يعني صحيه هاي هي اليوم كش ما
في مشكله بيحسن يدبر حاله بس كمان الشباب
يعني في عنا مشكله ثانيه انه الشباب
اغلبيه الناس لما طلعت من هناك طلعت من
الخرطوم من الخرطوم الناس طلعت من هناك ما
كانت حاسبه اي حساب نامت على على على شيء
وضغط على شيء اغلبيه الناس ما يعني ما
حاسبه اي حسابات للموضوع هذا طلعت هنا
الناس الان انا باكد لك كلها نفذت عندهم
المال ما قادر يوفر لعياله وشربه مي كثر
خير الشعب السوداني كتر خير جزاهم الله
الف خير الان
[موسيقى]
الشعب السوداني فضل على راسنا زمان والان
يعني الان في اخ اجى عرض قال يا جماعه في
مبنى بتالف من 600 غرفه ماكل مشرب
منامه حمامات كله اي عائله يجي يجي يسجل
ويدخل وهذا هو الشعب السوداني هذا الشعب
السوداني مشهوب مشهود له بالكرم وبالاخلاق
هذه فنحن اليوم بنناشد المملكه العربيه
السعوديه في انه العالم هذه يعني تعبت وما
عندها ملجا الا نحن العرب نفسنا يعني
تساعدنا يعني نحن اليوم شايف تشوف عينك
يعني كميات هائله والكميه الاكبر هي
السوريه وهي سوريه يعني انت بتعرف الظرف
اللي هي فيه اساسا من حرب لحرب فالان بس
عايزين حل في شباب عندهم مشاكل الان في
شباب عندهم مشاكل عندهم جيش مثلا هذا شلون
بدي اسوي اوضاعه
يعني هذه الصوره هي واضحه ولا تحتاج الى
مزيد تفسير عدد من الجاليات السوريه
واليمنيه تعاني نفس الاشكاليه هذا
الاقتظاظ هذا الوجود الضخم لمئات الاسر
الان يطالبون بالاسراع في الاجراءات حتى
يغادروا الاراضي السودانيه عبر البحر او
عبر الجو ومنها مباشره الى المملكه
العربيه السعوديه او الى عدد من الدول في
المنطقه والاقليم
بالتاكيد شكرا جزيلا مراسل العربيه نزار
البقلاوي من مدينه بورت سودان الان من
بورتسودان الى معبر ارجينا على الحدود
المصريه السودانيه مراسل العربيه احمد
عثمان احمد مشاهداتك حتى الان هل مازال
تدفق النازحين من من السودان الى مصر
مستمر
نعم مازال هذا التدفق مستمر حتى الان يعني
بحسب بياني وزاره الخارجيه المصريه كان قد
صدر مساء امس يعني ربما اكثر من 14 الف
سوداني تم يعني مرورهم من الحدود المصريه
من حيث اقف في معبر ارجين اكثر من 80%
منها هؤلاء السودانيون الذين عبروا الى
الحدود المصريه البقيه كانت من بعبر قسطل
ايضا هناك جهود لمرور عدد اخر سواء فيما
يتعلق بابناء الجاليه المصريه الذين ياتون
اغلبهم ايضا الى ارجين او من السفارات
الاجنبيه وايضا عمليات اجلاء مستمره
للمصريين فيما يتعلق بارسال طائرات عسكريه
الى المطارات العسكريه هناك ويعني حتى
الان العمل كما ذكرت لك على قدم وساق يعني
ربما المشهد لا يتغير كثيرا نفس يعني نفس
الشكاوى هناك يعني كان هناك حديث عن التعب
الذي تم الذي مر به والارهاق الذي يمر به
اغلب من ياتون خلال المنفذ بسبب الرحله
الطويله من الخرطوم وغيرها من المدن الى
المنفذ وايضا لبقائهم لفتره طويله انتهاء
للاجراءات التي كان من المفترض ان ربما
تنتهي خلال ساعات في اي ظروف عاديه ولكن
بسبب التكدس بسبب الالاف الذين جاؤوا الى
هذا المعبر بين ليله وضحاها وبسبب
الاجراءات الامنيه
والضمان سلامه الاجراءات سواء فيما يتعلق
بالبضائع والبشر والتاكد من الهويات وجوات
السفر والتاشيرات وغيرها من الامور
اللوجستيه التي تعاقدت بسبب هذا التكدس
الكبير ربما اخذ اربعه الامر بعض الوقت
وكان سبب ربما تذمر من قبل بعض الذين
يعبروا ولكن يعني الكل اكد بانها مرحله
استثنائيه ولحظه استثنائيه ويكملون
رحلاتهم مره اخرى الى كل من اسوان حيث
اغلبيه السودانيين الذين يتوجهون الى هناك
او الذين يفضلون التوجه الى القاهره بشكل
مباشر احمد كما فهمت ايضا هناك من هو يتجه
الى داخل السوداني
نعم بالفعل يعني انا في الامس كنت قد
اعددت تقريرا عن مجموعات تتجه الى الداخل
السوداني وكان ربما المشهد فيه مفارقه حيث
ان الالاف الفرق ما بين امطار التدفق يبدو
مكثفا من حيث بوابه الخروج ولكن ايضا هناك
زحام في انتظار فتح بوابه الدخول كنت قد
تحدثت مع كثير منهم لهم اسبابهم فيما
يتعلق بهذه العوده البعض يعيش في مدن
بعيده عن الاحداث البعض الاخر يريد ان
يطمئن على اهله وذويه وبيوته واعماله والى
اخره ولكن هناك ايضا من يتحدثون عن اهميه
وجود السودانيين في هذه اللحظه المراهنين
ربما على امكانيه ان يكون هناك نجاح لجهود
التسويه خلال المرحله المقبله الكل حزين
الكل عبر عن غضبه من هذا المشهد وهذه
المعاناه سواء على الطريقين المشكله بان
الدعم هناك الكثير من اللوجستيات التي
متعلقه فهناك من يقف على الجانب السوداني
في انتظار العبور المصري وهناك من يقف رغم
قله اعدادهم اذا ما قرينا بالجانب الاخر
من السود الذين يريد ان يعبروا الى
السودان من البوابه المتاخمه هذه النقطه
تحديدا لها علاقه بلوجاسيات العمل في
المعبر التي تفرض بان الحافلات التي تدخل
من اي جانب الى الجانب الاخر هي التي تقوم
بنقل المسافرين الاخرين من الجانب الاخر
وبالتالي كان المشهد ربما يعني فيه الكثير
من المفارقه هناك من يقف على الجانب الاخر
لمده ساعات وايام لهربا من الضرب للدخول
الى مصر وهناك ايضا البعض الذين يقفون نفس
هذه الفتره ولكن في الحدود المصريه في
انتظار وصول الحافلات للعبور للعوده الى
السودان مره اخرى احمد ايضا من خلال
الروايات لمن هم خرجوا من الخرطوم ماذا
يقولون هل تعرضوا لاطلاق نار هل هي الطريق
سالك امنه للخروج من الخرطوم حتى الوصول
حيث المعبر
نعم هناك تفاوت كبير في هذه الروايات يعني
هناك من يتحدثون الكل اجمع بان القصه او
التحدي الاصعب هي فكره الخروج من الخرطوم
ومن وسط الخرطومه ومن بحري هذه هي المدن
بحيث الاحداث الجسام حيث الضرب خلال ايام
الماضيه كان هناك من يتحدث عن قصف عشوائي
عن اطلاق نيران عشوائي عن مشاهدتهم لجثث
والى اخره ولكن الزاويه الاخرى من القصه
حينما تخرج من الخرطوم وتتجه الى الحدود
المصريه هناك من يتحدثون بان كان هناك بعض
المضايقات فرض ايتاوات ربما بل يتعرضون
لبعض اعمال السرقه فرض اموال يعني مبالغ
فيها جدا لنقلهم من قبل بعض الذين يقفون
في الطرق ولكن هناك من يتحدث ان عند نقطه
معينه بعد الخروج من الخرطوم وحتى الوصول
الى المنفذ البري كان هناك تامين جيد من
قبل قوات الجيش التي تنسقت مع القوات
المصريه او السلطات المصريه لتوفير ممرات
امنه هذه هي اغلب الروايات التي تحدث عنها
الجميع الضرب او تكثيف الضرب هي او التحدي
الاكبر هي فكره الخروج من وسط السودان من
حيث مرمى النيران ثم الانتقال بعد ذلك الى
محيطها حيث ان هناك بعض المضايقات ومن ثم
الارهاق المتعلق بالرحله الطويله في
الاروقه والدروب وصولا الى النقطه
الحدوديه المعبر الان
هادئ ام هناك تكدس حتى هذه اللحظه احمد
الناحيه المصريه من الناحيه المصريه نحن
لا نرى الا الحافلات التي تخرج من الجانب
السوداني او من المعبر يعني او الذين
يريدون المترجلين هناك معلومات بان هناك
استمرار للتكدس في الناحيه السودانيه
وايضا هناك استمرار للزحام داخل المعبر في
انتهاء الاجراءات ولكن بشكل عام اذا ما
قارنت هذه المشاهد من التكدس في الايام او
الساعات الماضيه القليله الماضيه بالايام
الاولى للازمه استطيع ان اقول بان هناك
نوع من التحسن الكبير والتسريع في الخروج
الكثير من المواطنين كما ذكرت لك هي مساله
اجراءات يجب ان تتبع اكثر ربما مرحله هي
التي تاخذ المزيد من الوقت هي المتعلقه
بمراجعه البيانات ايضا في مراجعه البضائع
بمراجعه السلع التاكد من الحصول على
التاشيرات كان هناك بعض المعلومات التي
خرجت واسرتك احمد يعني افهم انه انه هناك
ايضا حافلات لنقل البضائع تخرج من السودان
باتجاه باتجاه مصر طيب ماذا عن المدنيين
يتنقلون اغلبهم بحافلات حسب ما شاهد ام هي
سيارات خاصه
هذا الطريق للدخول الى السودان من خلال
البوابه من خلفي هذه النقطه المتعلقه
بالذين ياتون الى اسوان اخرون يتوجهون الى
القاهره قبل الحديث عن القاهره ايضا
استطيع ان اقول لك بان السلطات المصريه في
محاوله لمساعده اهالي السودان القادمين
قاموا يعني توفير عربات اضافيه للقطارات
لضمان ووصول اكبر نسبه ممكنه من سكان او
اهالي السودان الذين يريدون التوجه الى
القاهره والتقليل من معاناتهم بالاضافه
ايضا الى قرار اخر قاعده قد اتخذ بان من
لم يملك اموالا لدفعها كرسوم على المعبد
سيتم استثنائه هناك اخرين يفضلون التوجه
الى القاهره بشكل مباشر يقومون اما باخذ
حافلات الى اسوان ومنها الى القاهره او
الى اسوان ومنها بالقطارات الى القاهره
وهناك من يقررون ان يؤجرون بعض الحفلات
والتوجه مباشره مع القاهره رغم انها رحله
طويله تستغرق بالحافله ربما اكثر ما بعيده
اكثر من 10 ساعات الى 12 ساعه شكرا لمراسل
العربيه احمد عثمان من معبر ايرلين على
الحدود المصريه السودانيه
قال وزير خارجيه جنوب السودان
في تصريحات خاصه للعربيه ان بلاده مستمره
في جهودها لاقناع طرفي الصراع بوقف القتال
والتفاوض مضيفا ان جنوب السودان لم يحصل
على موافقه رسميه من البرهان بشان مبادره
ايجاد وان حكومته تجد صعوبه في الوصول الى
قائد الدعم السريع محمد حمدان دقلو هاتفيا
منذ سته ايام
ولقينا من
برهان طبعا من سته يوم حسي الاتصال
يمكن القائد
وتغير في المحال وتمشي للمهال معين
حتى في وقت
ما كان سايل انه الناس يكونوا اتصلوا في
اي وقت
رسلنا
رسلنا له رسلنا
البرهاند ورسلوه كمان
الرئيس الفقير نيابه عن الدول اللي جات
اعلن رئيس الوزراء الاثيوبيا باحمد عن
اجراء مباحثات هاتفيه مع قائد الجيش
السوداني عبد الفتاح البرهان وقائد قوه
الدعم السريع محمد حمدان دقلو بشان ضروره
تسويه الخلافات بين الجانبين واكد ابي
احمد عبر حسابه على تويتر ان هناك ناقش مع
البرهان
ضروره تحقيق الاستقرار في السودان وتسويه
الخلافات بعد الاشتباكات التي اندلعت بين
الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع
وقالت الخارجيه الاثيوبيه بانها تقدر
الظروف الذي التي يمر بها السودان وتبدو
القصار جهدها لدعم جهود الوقف الصراع كما
اشارت الخارجيه الاثيوبيه الى تشكيل لجنه
وطنيه اثيوبيه لتسهيل عبور النازحين من
الصراع في السودان واضافت بانها تامل في
ان يتوصل اطراف الصراع في السودان لاتفاق
دون التدخل الاطراف خارجيه
قال وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه انطوني
بلينكن ان الولايات المتحده ترحب باعلان
طرفي الصراع في السودان تمديد الهدنه الى
72 ساعه جديده واضاف بلنكن ان بلاده تحث
الاطراف السودانيه على الالتزام بوقف
القتال وضمان وصول المساعدات دون عراقيل
نعمل بشكل نشط لتمديد وقف اطلاق النار
كانت لدينا هدنه لمده 72 ساعه ورغم انها
لم تكن فتره مثاليه لكنها قللت من اعمال
العنف وخلق الظروفا افضل للسودانيين كما
ساعدت في تسهيل مرور المساعدات الانسانيه
ونريد التاكد ان كان ممكن ان تمديد الهدنه
فنحن منخرطون بشكل كبير
في لقاء خاصم مع العربيه قال المتحدث باسم
مجلس الامن القوميه في البيت الابيض جون
كيربي ان جهود بلاده مستمره لتمديد وقف
اطلاق النار في السودان مؤكدا العمل بصوره
حديثه مع طرفي الصراع لاجل ذلك
جهود مستمره من وزاره الخارجيه ويتراسها
السيد انتوني بلينكل لتمديد وقف اطلاق
النار في الايام المقبله ولقد راينا
تخفيضا في اعمال العنف التي طالت كافه
انحاء السودان لكن هناك بعض المناطق التي
لا تزال تشهد عنفا ومع ذلك تراجع العنف
ونعمل بصوره حديثه للتواصل مع الطرفين
لتمديد وقف اطلاق النار
نحن نرحب بمبادره ايجاد او اي مبادره اخرى
من اجل وقف القتال وادخال المساعدات
الانسانيه
شركاءنا السعوديون ساعدون كثيرا في اجلاء
مواطنين واجلاء اعداد كبيره من الرعايا
الاجانب عبر ميناء بورتسودان ونحن ممتنون
بما تقدمه في هذا الخصوص
دعا وزير الخارجيه البريطاني مواطنيه في
السودان الى الذهاب الى المطار في اسرع
وقت ممكن لضمان سلامتهم وقال في حسابه على
تويتر
تمديد وقف اطلاق النار في السودان المملكه
المتحده تدعو الى تنفيذها الكامل من قبل
الجنرالات
واضاف احث جميع الرعايه البريطانيين
الراغبين في مغادره السودان على التوجه
الى المطار في اسرع وقت ممكن لضمان
سلامتهم
المتحدثه باسم البيت الابيض كارين
قالت ان الوضع في السودان قد يتفاقم في اي
لحظه انه يتعين على الامريكيين المغادره
في غضون اليومين المقبلين
واضافت ان تحسن الوضع في السودان امر
مستبعد
بشان الانتهاكات المتزايده لوقف اطلاق
النار في السودان ندعو الجيش السوداني
وقوات الدعم السريع للالتزام الكامل
بالهدنه التي تم تمديدها وكما قال مستشار
الامن القومي جيكسوليفان ان الرئيس وجه
فريقه ببذل كل الجهود الممكنه لمساعده
الامريكيين هناك نعمل باستمرار على كل
الخيارات لمساعده الامريكيين على مغادره
السودان لان الوضع قد يتفاقم في اي لحظه
ونتواصل مع المواطنين الراغبين في
المغادره
اكدت وزاره الدفاع التركيه تعرض طائره
اجلاء تركيه لاطلاق نار بمطار وادي سيدنا
في الخرطوم موضحه ان طائره الاجلاء غادرت
مطار وادي سيدنا بسلام دون وقوع اي اصابات
جاء هذا في وقت اتهم فيه الجيش السوداني
قوات الدعم السريع باطلاق النار على طائره
اجلاء تركيه في مطار وادي سيدنا ما ادى
الى تضرر الطائره واصابه احد افراد طاقمها
وفق الروايه الجيش كما حذرت القوات
المسلحه السودانيه من وصفتهم بالمتمردين
من عرقله جهود الاجلاء بمثل هذه التصرفات
من جهتها نفت قوات الدعم السريع استهداف
الطائره التركيه طائره الاجلاء مؤكده
التزام قواتها بالهدنه الانسانيه التي
وافقت عليها
معنى من شمال الخرطوم مكه المغربيه الكاتب
الصحفي اهلا بك سيد مكي يعني كما نشاهد في
هذه الصور الخاصه بالعربيه ما زالت
الاوضاع الى الان غير مستقره في الخرطوم
هل من اشتباكات جديده تؤثر على هذه الهدنه
التي بدات عند الساعه الثانيه عشره
بالتوقيت المحلي للخرطوم
انا اعتقد المطلوب من الهدنه بالنسبه
للتحدثون عن الهدنه من خارج السودان وبعض
الدول هو اجلاء الرعايه الاجانب لكن وجود
هدنه فيما يلي المناطق التي فيها صراع او
اشتباكات بين الجيش
وماليزيا الدعم السريع
لن تتوقف لسبب جوهري واساسي انه حقيقه
وليس خيالا
قدره
قدره عناصر الدعم السريعه الان على
التواصل بينها على التنسيق على على طاعه
اوامر قيادتها على الانضباط مستحيله وهذا
ما افادت به عدد من المنظمات الدول
المحليه انها كانت تتواصل بسهوله بين
الطرفين في الممرات ولكن على سبيل المثال
منظمه الدوليه للتنميه والاغاثه قالت انها
فقدت الاتصال بقياده السريه منذ سته اشهر
ومن سته ايام
فلذلك عمليا يوجد طرف لا يستطيع ان يضبط
قواته وهذه حقيقه ويوجد طرف اخر
الجيش السوداني هو ملزم بان يوافق على
الهدنه من اجل التزاماته الدوليه
والانسانيه حتى لا يقال انه رفض الهدنه
ولكن طبيعه الواقع انه
ما ان تعلن الهدنه الا ويبدا الاشتباك الى
حد ما كان سهل هذا الامر الى الرعايه
الاجانب ولكن وضح تماما ان يعني بقايا
مليشيا الدعم السريع لا تستطيع ان تضبط
نفسها في اقتحام مقر سفارات او استهداف
طائرات اشياء يعني هذا الامر لا ياتي
باوامر من قيادتها اعتقد قيادتها
السيد مكي اذا سمحت اذا سمحت يا سيد مكي
الان وصلتنا هذه الصور من غرب دارفور
لعمليات نزوح
[موسيقى]
بالشكل
الخرطوم هناك
اعود الى شمال الخرطوم وتحديدا الى السيد
مكي المغربي الكاتب الصحفي سيد مكي يعني
اليوم نحن نتحدث انه هذه العمليات عمليات
النزوح عمليات النزوح من من الخرطوم من
دار فورد يبدو ان روقعه على اقتتال تتوسع
كما كان متوقعا في بدايات نشوب هذا
الاقتتال بين الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع
ايضا الخارجيه الامريكيه قالت انه تحسن
الوضع في السودان هو امر مستبعد الان
وبالتالي عمليات الاجلاء في ازدياد وتصاعد
مستمر
عمليات النزوح مستمره ما يحدث الانصرافه
دارفور هو اصلا الصراع موجود
ووصل الى حد انه صراع بين الدعم السريع
نفسه وبين الدعم السريع والجيش من جهه
واصلا انتشار السلاح والمكونات المسلحه في
دارفور موجود حركه النزوح تتجه شمالا
بارقام ضخمه الى مصر
وغربا في تشابه يوجد نزوح ويوجد
نزوح عبري اثيوبيا لكن مثلا النزوع عبر
اثيوبيا هو معبر للسفر خارج السودان
النزوح الى مصر هو نزوح بغرض الاقامه في
مصر لانه مصر هي الان الدوله الوحيده التي
تستضيف السودانيين والدوله الوحيده التي
تقوم بشراكه
تقول عوده الاذاعه السودانيه للبث بعد
توقفها بسبب المعارك
بس خليني اقرا هذا الخبر العاجل اذا تكرمت
سيد مكي مصادر الجيش السوداني تقول عوده
الاذاعه السودانيه للبث بعد توقفها بسبب
المعارك ارجو ان يكون صدرك متسع للمقاطعه
لانه هناك عواجل كثيره تاتي وبالتالي يجب
ان نقرا هذه الانباء العاجله بعد اذنك
يعني تفضل
يوجد نقطه يجب ان نكملها
ايضا الخبر العاجل يجب ان نقراه اتفضل
نعم
لا ما سالت هذا يجب ان اقرا الخبر العاجل
فقط للتوضيح تفضل
تفضل
بموضوع الدفاع الصبر وهل يمكنني ان اكمل
الان
تفضل سيد مكي
طيب النصر تتحمل المشكله الانسانيه مع
السودان دون غيرها من الدول العربيه يوجد
جهود من بعض الدول لاجراء رعايه اجانب لكن
لا توجد دوله عربيه الان تتحمل لاجئين
سودانيين لذلك انا اعتقد دور مصر في حل
هذه المشكله يجب ان يكون دور اساسي وكبير
بخصوص
تجدد الصراعات في دارفور كما ذكرت انها
اصلا صراعات موجوده
وستندلع يعني
بذات الوتيره الاشكاليه الان انك تتحدث مع
طرف على ارض الواقع لا يستطيع ضبط قواته
هذا اولا ثانيا الحديث بان هذا الصراع هو
صراع بين طرفين او صراع بين البرهان على
السلطه هذا تغبيش الواقع الواقع ان هنالك
رفض من الجيش السوداني على مدى اربع سنوات
بل مدى اكثر من ذلك منذ تاسيس الدعم
السريع هنالك الرفض قاطع من الجيش
السوداني لتضخم هذه الميليشيا وتحولها الى
قوات مسلحه لذلك الامر ليس بيد البرهان او
بانه تعنت من البرهان او طلب سلطه من
البرهان او صراع من البرهان وحماتي هذا
صراع بين الجيش قومي ومليشيا واضح متمرده
واضح سيد مكي الان يعني في ظل هذه
العمليات عمليات الاجلاء في ظل ايضا
التجدد الاقتتال واتساع رقعه ايضا
المؤشرات كلها تدل لربما الى تعاظم هذه
المشكله وليس حلها هل باتا
بالادوار الاقليميه الادوار الدوليه ربما
اي مكان للصلح او خرو ج السودان من هذه
الازمه
غير الهدنه الهشه
بالتاكيد انا اتوقع ان ينتهي الامر
توجد وساطات داخليه من السودان
هذه الوصابات تتحدث عن خروج امن لمقاتلي
الدعم السريع من الخرطوم بالرغم ان الجيش
يطالب بالاستسلام
الكامل او الانضمام للقوات المسلحه ولكن
بعض الوصفات القبليه ترغب فيما يسمى
بالخروج الامن او السيف
خرطوم
الحديث عن محاوله للضغط على البرهان
بعقوبات امميه ودوليه وبالدول التي تسمي
نفسها صديقه وهي تدعم الدعم السريع سرا في
صراعه ضد الجيش
القومي السوداني هذه
الضغوط تسفر على شيء البرهان بين عقوبات
وبين سقط جيشه فيختار العقوبات
يعني انا ارى من من التبسيط بمكان يعني
افتراض ان البرهان موجود وانه سيتخذ قرار
غدا في مصالحه الدعم لم ينتهي الامر اسمح
لي فقط يعني الان المصادر العربيه تشير
الى ان مبعوث
لقائد الجيش البرهان سيبدا قائد مجلس
سياده سيبدا جوله خارجيه باعتقادك ما هي
الملفات التي سيحملها ولمن
ممارسه الجيش السوداني الحكومه السودانيه
للدبلوماسيه الخارجيه بما في ذلك
اموال الموافقه في لحظه ما انا اتوقعها
على التقاء مع موثول ممثل لدعم السريعه
يعتقد هذا الامر وارد وحتى لو حدث انا لا
اعتقد انه هو قرار بايقاف الحرب مع الدعم
السريع او ايقاف توجه الحسم العسكري اخي
الكريم انا اتحدث لك عن احتقان على الاقل
لمده اربع سنوات
والاشكاليه ان المبعوثين الدوليين والدول
والرباعيه وغيرها كانت ترمي بثقلها في وضع
لتقنين وجود الدعم السريع والجيش السوداني
يرفض ويضغط على البرهان انه يجب ان يقبل
هذا الامر قبل في النهايه توقيعه الاتفاق
الاطار على مضض
بالقبول بدمج الدعم السريع في خلال عامين
بعدها بدا الدعم السريه يتحدث عن انه لم
يندمج الا في خلال العشر سنوات ثم توجهت
قواته الى مدينه مروي القوى السياسيه بدلا
من
تفضل نعم القوى السياسيه المدعومه خارجيا
بالذات من الرباعيه تاتي فيها امريكا
وبريطانيا والسعوديه والامارات
اعتقد انها وقفت محايده بين الجيش
السوداني والدعم السريع طيب والشعب
السوداني لن ينسى هذا الامر ابدا كل ذلك
قراءه شكرا جزيلا يا سيده مكه المغربيه
الكاتب الصحفي من شمال الخرطوم شكرا جزيلا
لك
[موسيقى]
الان الى موجز لابرز الاخبار الدوليه افاد
المسؤولون الاوكرانيون بان روسيا اطلقت
اكثر من عشرين صاروخ كروز وطائرتين دون
طيار على العاصمه كييف واجزاء اخرى من
اوكرانيا حيث هو اسفر الهجوم الروسي عن
مقتل خمسه اشخاص على الاقل ضرب مبنى سكني
في وسط اوكرانيا
قال وزير الدفاع الاوكراني
ان كييف اصبحت جاهزه لشن هجوم مضاد على
القوات الروسيه وانها شارفت على نهايتها
واضاف وزير الدفاع الاوكرانيه ان هناك
عوامل لا تهيئ هذه الاستعدادات العسكريه
للهجوم المضاد منها عوامل الطقس وحيثيه
القرار من قبل القاده للبدء والشروع في
العمليات العسكريه المضاده
اعتبر مجلس اوروبا في قرارنا اعتمدته
جمعيته البرلمانيه ان نقل روسيا اطفالا
اوكرانيين بالقوه الى اراضيها يرقى الى
مستوى اباده جماعيه ودع المجلس الى اعاده
الاطفال بامان الى اوكرانيا مشيرا الى ان
هذه العمليات مخطط لها بوضوح وتنظم بشكل
منهجي كسياسه دوله بهدف القضاء على اي
رابط مع هويتهم الاوكرانيه اتهم وزير
الدفاع الروسي الولايات المتحده وحلفائها
باستفزاز بعض الدول في مقدماتها روسيا
الصين لجرها الى مواجهه عسكريه مع دول
معارضه واضاف ان الهدف الحقيقي من هذه
السياسه التي تتبعها واشنطن هو الحاق
هزيمه استراتيجيه في روسيا وتشكيل تهديد
للصين للحفاظ على مكاداتها الاحتكاريه في
العالم
خبر السواحل الفلبينيه انه دخل في مواجهه
خطيره مع سفن صينيه قامت بمناورات في بحر
الصين الجنوبي حيث اشار الى ان سفينه
صينيه اجرت مناورات خطيره على بعد 45 مترا
تقريبا من سفينه فلبينيه وان سفينتين
اخريين نفذت تكتيكات عدائيه شكلت تهديدا
على سلامه السفينه الفلبينيه وطاقمها من
جانبها الصين اتهمت الفلبين وقالت بانها
قامت بعمل
استفزازي متعمد وحاولت التسبب في حادث في
بحر الصين الجنوبي
قالت وكررت عمليات التجاره البحريه
البريطانيه انها تلقت تقارير تفيد بتعرض
سفينه لهجوم الى الجنوب من بلده نشطون
الساحليه اليمنيه وذكرت الوكاله في بيان
ان عيرة الناريه اطلقت على السفينه
البريطانيه كما اشارت ايضا الى وجود ثلاثه
قوارب على متن كل منها ثلاثه او اربعه
اشخاص
رحب اعضاء مجلس الامن بزياره الاخيره التي
اجراها الوفد السعودي والعماني الى صنعاء
واثناء على دعم السعوديه وسلطنه عمان
المستمر لجهود الوساطه التي تبذلها الامم
المتحده واعتبر المجلس ان مثل هذه
المحادثه تمثل خطوات قيمه نحو وقف شامل
لاطلاق النار ومحادثات سياسيه يمنيه يمنيه
شامله تحت رعايه المبعوث الامامي الى
اليمن وذلك بناء على المرجعيات المتفق
عليها وقرار مجلس الامن
الان نعود الى استكمال تغطيه احداث
السودان والتطورات دائما مع نايف الاحمري
دمتم في رعايه الله
طبعت المزيد
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات